j'ai eu un trou dans le pied elle m'a
transpercé le pied elle c'est l'âge et
allie la grenade lacrymogène instantané
c'est en 2009 que pascale vaillant a été
touché par ce projectile en pleine
manifestation à saint nazaire un modèle
de jerry particulièrement puissants
c'est une arme extrêmement dangereuse
mais en fait la grenade lacrymogène est
utilisé dans les manifestations depuis
elle a connu ses heures de gloire en mai
68 et quel que soit le modèle de gea lee
elles causent des dégâts depuis bien
longtemps
la première fois que la télé mais tant
qu'à en lumière c'est en 1986 jérôme 18
ans manifestent contre la hausse des
prix d'inscription à l'université
quand il est frappé par un tir de
grenade qui lui fracture le crâne
pourquoi la police a chargé des enfants
qui étaient désarmées qu'il
n'envisageait pas de cacher quoi que ce
soit ce soit même si par ailleurs il y
avait peut-être des provocateurs leur
métier de circonscrire les provocateurs
et pas de lancer des grenades à hauteur
d'homme qui plus est des blessés par
grenade lacrymogène
il y en aura encore comme cet homme à
lille en 2000 heurts lors d'une
manifestation de pompiers lui n'a pas
été visé mais à ramasser le projectile
pour l'éloigner il a perdu une 1 il y
avait un petit bosquet je voulais
balancier là dedans mais malheureusement
dans les lancements
la grenade a explosé et j'ai subi bien
tardivement hier ou aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs que c'était une vanne à deux
défensives une grenade défensive mais
explosive dangereuse son usage est
réglementée elle ne peut être utilisé
sans autorisation de la hiérarchie mais
la règle ne serait pas toujours
respectée par les agents un acte écrit
est obligatoire
visiblement de la préfecture je ne pense
pas
à partir de 2011 le mode lg ally f4 fait
son apparition
c'est elle qui a causé de nombreuses
blessures depuis le mouvement des gilet
jaune
en plus de son effet lacrymogènes elle
est très bruyante et produit un effet de
souffle sa dangerosité est accrue à
cause de la tnt qui lui permet
d'exploser
aujourd'hui la gldf 4 n'est plus
fabriqué en attendant que les forces de
l'ordre et puisent des stocks
les agents sont dotés d'une nouvelle
grenade la g m2 elle un modèle présenté
comme moins dangereux
[Musique]